for this type of situation are already
in train it's absolutely right that we
now are Vigilant that is what the public
would expect and that is what we are
doing
this includes robust screening processes
on arrival at Western jetfoil in Dover
to proactively identify those with
symptoms of diphtheria
round-the-clock health facilities at
manston including emergency department
consultants and paramedics
guidance in multiple languages on
spotting the symptoms of diphtheria an
enhanced dip theory of vaccination
program offering to all those arriving
at manston and I can confirm that of
those who arrived at the facility this
weekend 100 took up that vaccine offer
testing for those presenting themselves
with symptoms and for close contacts of
those cases
those testing positive are being
isolated in a designated place
today we're going above and beyond the
UK HSA Baseline by instituting new
guidance on the transportation and
accommodation of individuals displaying
diphtheria symptoms so from today no one
presenting with symptoms will progress
into the Asylum accommodation system
they will either remain at manston
isolating for a short period or they
will travel to a designated isolation
Center in Secure transport where they
will be treated until deemed medically
fit this is a well-practiced protocol
from covert times
we will also continue to ensure all
Asylum accommodation providers are given
access to the very latest Public Health
advice from the UK HSA and are aware of
their responsibilities for testing and
isolating cases of infectious diseases
we'll continue working with the UK HSA
to ensure that the arrangements of the
highest standard and the UK HSA has
everything that it needs from the home
office
we're engaging with French counterparts
to assess the state of infectious
diseases in the camps in northern France
Mr Speaker I fully understand and
appreciate the concerns that have been
raised and I can assure the house that
the home office acutely aware of our
responsibility both to those in care but
also to the British public
for myself for the Home Secretary and
for the government as a whole public
health is Paramount and we will take all
steps necessary to ensure that the
public are protected I commend this
statement to the house
without come to the shutter sector
estate a vet Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker and also for your
words about obviously it was difficult
to respond to a statement after just 10
minutes but I thank the minister
immigration Minister for the information
he's given us I have to say why is the
Home Secretary not here this is supposed
to be her top priority we've had two uqs
a debate and this statement in the last
few weeks on this chaos and she hasn't
done any of them you have to ask what is
she for she obviously doesn't have a
grit and she has made this chaos worse
the government has failed to stop the
proliferation of criminal gangs in the
channel is still refusing to adopt
Labor's proposal for a new National
Crime agency unit to Target the gangs
and has failed to sort out the chaos in
Asylum decision making so they are only
taking around half as many as six years
ago even though they have more staff and
just two percent of last year's small
boat cases have been decided creating a
backlog of nearly a hundred thousand
people waiting more than six months for
a decision compared to just four
thousand when they took office all of
which has led to a completely
inappropriate use of hotels at the last
minute with no proper information for
local councils and no proper information
for public health officials and then of
course the chaotic handling of the
situation at manston
the information that the minister has
just given us is that there are 50
diphtheria cases can he confirm that
that compares to just three last year
can you tell us when ministers were
first told of diphtheria cases at
manston when were they warned by the
mid-october the home office admitted
publicly that there were cases at
manston but on the 26th of October the
home office officials told the select
committee they had sufficient Health
Arrangements in place to address
diphtheria clearly they did not the
government still kept thousands of
people in overcrowded conditions
described by one person as being huddled
around Fan heaters thousands of people
in overcrowded conditions trying to stay
warm clearly these are conditions which
make it easy for infectious diseases to
spread
the process is that he has just
described now clearly are important but
why on Earth were they not put in place
many weeks ago it took until 11th the
11th of November after thousands of
people had been held there for weeks in
manston for weeks for screening and
vaccinations on diphtheria to be
recommended for everyone passing through
Mountain what on Earth were they doing
in the meantime because even then on
that very same day the home office was
moving people who'd been in manston into
hotels across the country without even
telling councils or public health
officials and including in one case
specifically telling the council these
were not transfers from manston even
though they were others where councils
were told nothing at all and no
information for public health officials
about whether people needed further
diphtheria screening and vaccinations
including leaving people to seek
treatment for themselves for diphtheria
symptoms at local A and E departments
the health secretary has said that 500
people have now been screened and
vaccinated what about the other several
thousand people who have been in manston
wherever they now are in the country
have they been screened or vaccinated
for diphtheria as well if not why on
Earth not because that was the public
health recommendation nearly three weeks
ago and that was already late have all
those with possible symptoms now been
given precautionary antibiotics again if
not why not we're told dip theory is an
easy infection to treat and to vaccinate
against which is why we have a universal
vaccination policy in the UK but that
needs proper information for health
officials to be able to use and it needs
the home office to get a grip and
clearly the government has ignored
Health advice
and also ignored legal advice
Terry said publicly that when he was
Health once was home office Minister he
was advised he had to act as he was
breaking the law the permanent secretary
has said now the Home Secretary was
given the same legal advice so why
didn't she act either on the legal
advice or on the health advice
I'm sure the immigration minister is
working really hard to try and sort this
out the problem is that everyone else is
struggling to clear up the home
secretary's chaos and she isn't even
here it is chaotic this issue is too
important not to have a grit in place
and if the Home Secretary is too fret to
attend this house and take
responsibility for her decisions she
should get out the way and let someone
else do the job